I've watched your video on juicy obsidian fuzzy and what I should do according to my genetics so so I do have a video juicy versus blending if you haven't seen that you can go it's probably on the member site it's certainly on our YouTube channel.
There's positives and negatives to both you see and blending so one of the things that I recommend based upon genetics so we talk about genetics precondition to whether a person should use or they should blend has to do with the gene called that H I F one gene.
So the H I F one gene I have a video on it you can watch it's in the genetics.
Read your genes course might also even be on the member site because the H I F one gene is important with cancer patients if you have a lot of defects in this gene it means that you can your cancer can be fed it has a higher degree chance that it's fed
your cancer is fed through glycolicis so if your cancer is fed by glycolicis that means it's using using glucose right so if it's using glucose to feed on you don't want to be juicy as much.
So juicing is taking out all the fiber out of a food product and you're just getting the juice now the proponents of juicing say that's the way to go you don't need all that fiber you can drink a whole lot more juice if the fiber is removed so therefore you're putting it through a juicer.
There's different varieties I'll get into that but then you are drinking that juice and an ingerson protocol you're drinking you know anywhere between you know eight and 15 glasses of this juice a day that's a whole lot of ounces of juice which is very concentrated any juice even vegetable juice even breed juice is going to have a lot of glucose but certainly if you're going to add carrots apple salary which is a typical
production type juice mixture to be very high in glucose you got a lot of HIF one defects chance that your cancer is using glucose as a fuel source is very high probably not a good idea of juice.
So is it aren't you getting the same amount of sugar when you blend or remember when you measure your total numbers of grams of glucose that you're consuming in a given day you can instantly subtract the grams of fiber that you're consuming so if I look at a product and the product has
6 grams glucose and it has it has a 3 grams fiber then I then I really only have a total of 3 grams of total glucose because the fiber will attach to the glucose and it's the same way with with the fiber.
If you're blending if you're blending you're getting all the fiber of the product as well you're really offsetting the glucose you won't be able to drink nearly as much if somebody could drink 13 glasses of blended vegetables a day they would probably explode you can't do that so you'll drink a whole lot less you're going to get fiber with it will help offset some of the glucose.
So if you have HIF one defects or have I've told you that you have to really be out of low sugar diet I would suggest you know either doing a little bit of juicy not a lot of juicy or doing blending.